- So your husband does
something nice for you
with memorabilia,
like from the past.
- [Christina] Yeah.
What is it? Can you explain?
- I have never saved
anything from my career,
anything, like, I don't
have my magazine covers
when I was younger.
I didn't save any of it.
And he thinks that that's,
he like is encouraging me to be very proud
of my career and everything.
So he's gone back and bought,
found them all on eBay
and bought them for me
(crowd aww)
and is like saving, I know, he's very,
very sweet.
- It's kind of an
amazing scrapbook too.
I always think now as a
mom, like for your kids.
- [Christina] Yeah.
- That's the only reason
why I keep anything now, 'cause I'm like,
they might not care, but they might.
I don't know.
- Yeah, it's true.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- When I was little
I really cared about my mom's,
my mom was a model and so she had her book
with all her tear sheets,
and I really did care about that.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So I get,
I get his point.
- Yeah.
- About like the kids wanting it and
it also like it's nice,
and I think now that it's,
most of those magazine
covers are like 20 years old,
and now that I'm 20
years from that person.
- It's like removed
from it.
- I'm able to
be like, "Oh yeah, that was great."
You know?
- Yeah.
And you look, I always look
at things and people show me,
and I'm just like, oh my
God, I was like a baby.
- Yeah, exactly, feels
like a different person.
- It really does.
I love age.